>>Narrator: Arne Duncan was appointed
CEO of Chicago Public Schools
in 2001 by Mayor Richard Daley.
A champion of community schools
and after-school programs,
Duncan helped create
the Ariel Academy,
a unique public school backed by a
private firm that supplies each class
with a $20,000.00 stock
portfolio to manage.
He graduated magna cum laude
from Harvard University
and was co-captain of
the basketball team.
He has played professionally
in Australia
and in countless pickup games
with President-elect Barack Obama.
>>Arne: I was just so lucky to grow
up -- I was always the young guy.
I was part of my mother's program,
so I'd grow up playing against guys
who were a lot older and a lot
better than me and was able to learn
from them and get beaten enough times
to get a little toughness maybe,
but it's just sort of shaped me
growing up, and I was able to sort
of travel the city and play in
playgrounds all over the South
and West Side, and you just
learn so much through sports.
It's all the values that we're trying
to instill in our kids of hard work
and unselfishness and being part
of a team and teamwork and sort
of sacrificing personal goals or
personal glory for the larger good.
And it's easy to talk
about those values.
It's another thing to try
and live them and living them
on whether it's a basketball court
or a football field or
whatever it might be.
I think sports is just an
extraordinary teaching ground,
and so I was able to have great,
great mentors like John Rogers
and others, who I learned
from, and those lessons
on the court have helped to shape my
character and I'm so lucky for that.
I got to play in lots
of neighborhoods
that were tough neighborhoods and
you learned to judge character very,
very quickly and who you could
trust and who you couldn't.
And I wouldn't be doing
what I'm doing today
if I didn't have those skills,
and it's a real way for me
to relate to our students.
I'll go out and play
with the high school kids
or play the elementary kids and
rather than seeing a guy in a suit,
you can sweat a little bit and
have a real nice shared experience,
and then you can really sit down and
talk afterwards and get a real sense
from students in terms of
what's working, what's not,
so it's been a real bridge-builder
for me and it's a lot of fun as well.
>>Overall, I'm extraordinarily
proud of the progress we're making.
Over the past five years,
we've actually improved at more
than twice the rate of
the rest of the state.
It's been dramatic improvements.
We are absolutely closing
the achievement gap.
Twenty years ago we were called
the worst school system in America
by the former secretary of
education, Bill Bennett.
I don't know whether
that was true or not,
but we definitely didn't have a
school system we could be proud of.
We've come an extraordinarily
long way,
particularly since the
mayor took over in 1995.
But our goal is very ambitious.
We want to go from worst to best,
and I absolutely am convinced
that we have a chance to
become the best big city,
the best urban school system in
the country over the next couple
of years, and that's what we're
trying to work extraordinarily hard
to do and there are lots of
strategies we can get into,
but the bottom line is we have
to dramatically increase
graduation rates.
We need to continue to
dramatically reduce dropout rates,
and we have to make sure all of our
students upon graduation are ready
to go to college and have the
academic skills or are ready to go
into the world of work,
and ultimately that's how
I want to be measured.
>>The core of our work is a focus
on instructional excellence,
sort of a back-to-basics curriculum
and reading, first and foremost,
and I'm just convinced that if
we can teach our children to read
and to love to read at an early
age that they have this world
of opportunity available to them
if they can express their
ideas verbally and on paper.
And if we don't do that well,
frankly, nothing else we do matters,
so it's a huge, huge laser-like focus
on great instruction, great teaching
and a laser-like focus on literacy.
Second is what we call our
"Human Capital Initiative,"
which is really trying to
recruit the best and brightest
into every level of the organization.
We've gone from 9,000
applicants wanting to teach
in Chicago public schools
to over 20,000 applicants.
We're actually more
selective than universities
like Stanford now in terms of hiring.
WE have about 12 applicants
for every position.
>>The third-quarter
strategy's a bit of a broad one.
I call it sort of more
learning opportunities.
It's sort of challenging
the assumption that --
if I don't really think a school
day that is five days a week,
six hours a day, nine
months a year --
I just think that's an
outmoded model; it's broken.
It's based on the agrarian economy.
Last time I checked here
in Chicago not too many
of our children are working in farms,
and so we have to do a lot more,
so after-school programming
is a huge one for me,
really making our schools,
community centers open long hours,
where our schools can become
the hearts of the community,
make good things happen for children
and going to more detail on that.
We're trying to do a lot on
early childhood education,
getting to children younger, three-
and four-year-olds, more preschool,
more full-day kindergarten.
We can get those literacy
skills intact.
When our students hit
kindergarten, they're ready to go,
and then finally we have
a very ambitious effort
that the mayor's done a great job
leading called the Renaissance 2010
Initiative to create 100 great new
schools in the city by the year 2010,
and we're about halfway there.
We opened 15 great
new schools this fall.
We're at about 48 total now.
We have 17 planned for fall
'07, and we want to, again,
continue to create
great, new opportunities
where they haven't existed
historically, and so there's a range
of just more -- the large bucket I
use has more learning opportunities,
more time on task, more time during
the day, getting to children younger
and creating more opportunities
where they didn't exist.
But those three core strategies,
instructional excellence,
getting the best and brightest
to work at every level
of the organization and trying
to do more for our children,
both in terms of early childhood
and after school, more new schools,
if we can continue to execute
on those every single year,
I'm convinced we'll get
where we need to go.
>>This piece of it's
a really personal one.
My mother tried to start an
after-school program in 1960
and started it at the local public
school, and they didn't allow her to,
so she had to start
-- she had to work
in the church basement
across the street.
And then about 30 years later, my
sister and I came back and tried
to also start an after-school
program, and we weren't allowed
into the schools and so we ended
up in the same church
basement as my mother.
And so when I got in this position,
the first thing I said we'd do is
that we'd open the
schools to the community,
that these are these
fabulous resources.
We have over 600 buildings.
Every single one have classrooms and
libraries and computer labs and gyms
and you name it, swimming pools,
these fabulous physical resources
that previously at two-thirty in
the afternoon the kids were swept
out of there and into the streets.
It's incomprehensible to me.
And so what we tried to
do is create a culture
where we welcomed the
children but, most importantly,
welcomed the community in
with all the nonprofits
and social-service agencies
who are now providing
services in the schools.
And we have a set of over 100
schools now that're open 11, 12, 13,
14 hours a day, 6 days a week,
11 months out of the year
with a whole host of
after-school programming,
whether it's academic enrichment
for our students but also drama
and sports and music and
chess and debate and yearbook,
whatever it might be, and then
activities for older brothers
and sisters and parents
as well: GED and ESL
and family-literacy nights
and family counseling.
And, again, I'm just convinced
where school becomes the true heart,
the true center of the
community, which is the center
of a family's life, our students are
going to do extraordinarily well,
and we're seeing those results.
This is hard work, and, again,
it's harder to keep schools open.
It's messier.
It's dirtier.
You got to figure out hours;
there's some challenges there,
but it's the right thing to do and
our children desperately need it,
and they need it more than ever,
and to me this is an issue that cuts
through race and class, whether it's
two parents or both parents working
in an affluent family
or whatever it might be,
whether it's a single mom working
whether it's a job or two jobs
or three jobs, or we have
about 9,000 homeless students,
and whether it's students going
home, frankly, to no-parent families,
whatever the family situation,
whatever the socioeconomic status,
our children need great
after-school programming.
We have some extraordinary kids.
We have some extraordinary kids
who're beating the odds every single
day after coming from some very tough
situations, and we owe it to them
to do our best and to create the
best opportunities possible for them.
I can't think of anything
I'd rather be doing.
>>I've been fortunate
growing up as part
of my mother's after-school program
to see phenomenal young people
who happen to be poor, happen not
to always have the most
put-together families,
but to see how much those students
wanted to succeed academically
and to see how successful they were,
given her support and other support
over the long haul, and so rather
than just running an after-school
program, could you create a school?
And then if you could do
that, could you create a --
creating a system of schools,
a whole city of schools
that really help students
fulfill their tremendous academic
and social potential.
Quite frankly, most of the
time growing up as part
of my mother's program the
public schools were the enemy.
We were trying to do from three
o'clock to eight o'clock at night
with students what wasn't
happening during the school day.
And I'm a little radical on this.
I think when public
education doesn't do its job,
public education perpetuates poverty
and perpetuates social failure.
And, when it does do its
job, it really is the --
it opens the door of
opportunity to the mainstream
of America and to the middle class.
And so, for me, it's a labor
of love; it's a passion,
and I think quality public
education is the civil rights issue
of our generation.
>>Ariel is how I got my
start in public education.
I ran John Rogers'
nonprofit Ariel Foundation
for about six years starting in
1992, and in 1995 we were young
and dumb enough to think that we
could create a great public school,
and that was one of the first things
the mayor did when he took control
of the public schools in 1995, along
with the previous CEO, Paul Vallas
and the board chair Gery Chico.
They issued an RFP,
request for proposals,
for groups that were interested
in running new schools,
new public schools.
And myself and my sister and a
small team of us, again, were young
and naïve enough to think that
we had a few ideas about how
to create great education in
the heart of the inner city,
and we had applied and we were one
of six groups chosen
to open new schools.
It has enabled us to do lots
of things you couldn't just do
as a public school here, because
public education in Illinois is
so desperately underfunded.
So, whether it's a
curriculum director,
whether it's extensive after-school
programming, whether it's a chance
for our students to actually
invest in real stocks and be part
of this investment curriculum,
which is this fascinating whole
series of summer opportunities.
Literally today we have almost
50 of the Ariel Academy students
at a McDonald's board
meeting with [inaudible],
and it's just been a phenomenal
partnership and it is exactly a model
that we'd love to try and replicate
and get other companies to step up
and similarly invest and invest
deeply and over the long haul
with a school and really make a huge
difference in those students' lives.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.